Why does it see more people are susceptible to issues with bedbedness all?
Well, so the issues that a person would have with any medication have to do with
their ability to detoxify said medication. So if
let's say let's say I have a
decreased ability to detoxify bedbedness all, then bedbedness all is going to do more damage to my liver and
that's that's why I would that's that made issue a person would have
So even if bedbedness all was working to kill the cancer
You know, you know, you don't want to kill the patient by causing liver failure
And then you die of liver failure and you didn't die of cancer when that makes no sense whatsoever. So it's a matter of balancing between
Being able to tolerate bedbedness all and how you'd measure any drugs
toleration would be a do you have side effects of that medication will typically with bedbedness all there's not side effects of the medication so much
But B, are there other physical effects on
Your on tissues in the main tissue that you're looking for with any medication is the liver because the liver has to detoxify it now
There's certain detoxification pathways that we could look at genetically different side of chrome people P450 pathways
Pud one pathways and a tea pathways
And gluttonial pathways if you have issues with any of those major detoxification pathways
genetically you have
possibility of a
Greater issues in the in your ability to detoxify said medication
But even if you had no defects in any of the
genetic pathways, there's other acquired issues that you could have with your liver
Maybe you you know you took a lot of medication. You're exposed a lot of toxins
You drank a lot of alcohol whatever so you already have
Physically impaired pathways even though not genetically impaired pathways. So if you have any physical impairment of those pathways
Either you're liver you're going to have a
Greater difficulty detoxifying a medication
Not just bedbedness all to keep a therapy or it's I've erected it or it's Tylenol
Whatever it is you can have a difficult time
Getting rid of that
So if you don't get rid of it it does damage to your tissue right so whatever you don't get rid of becomes a part of you
And it can damage your cells and typically medications are going to do damage to your liver
They can do damage to other things as well just like I just mentioned in the brain antibodies question
So if you know, you know, chemotherapy can cross the blood brain barrier cause inflammation of the brain called prime cause prime glial cells
cause
Antibodies being developed in neuronal tissue
Well, it can save things
chemotherapy not only can help tip over cancer cells and kill them, but it can also
Then catch 22 is it can damage healthy cells
Because it's a very strong oxidizing agent that doesn't spare healthy cells
So those are side effects of different medications
So there's difference between side effects of medication and the inability to detoxify a medication
So typically the
Problems that a person would have with the metasol is it is difficulty in detoxify you know
And detoxify that metasol it has to do with
energetic pathways as well as acquired
Issues in those genetic pathways